my name is reto Meier I am E&E Lewis and
today on the a clinic will be examining
shopping lists gotta love that intro
haha all right each week on the App
clinic we take a look at apps within a
particular category and we give them a
technical review our focus on helping
developers build better apps so we'll be
interspersing our commentary with some
technical advice including some code
snippets now the hope is that those of
you who are watching as well as the
developers whose apps were reviewing
will you know learn a few tips and
tricks and best practices creating apps
that will delight your users we're all
about the delight here so this week like
I said we're looking at shopping apps to
be more specific apps that help you shop
by letting you write lists of things to
shop for right so shopping list acts
basically yeah okay so there's four apps
on the patient list today they are out
of milk grocery IQ zoom tasks and some
french thing that we don't know how to
pronounce it for cooking praying we're
gonna go with prick Singh it's if there
are any French language speakers
watching please let producer lewis know
so you can correct us live on air cuz we
do like to be correct we're just
moccasin the youtube comments that's all
the time that's pretty much standard
practice so by the way tell anyone that
if the if the dude that thinks we work
for Apple is back say hey and we you
know I was thinking about like how could
we prove that we're working for google I
no way it's it's hot I mean we're in
front of a green screen here anyone can
be a potato right now yeah not but it's
just a little camera punched into Andy's
old office at least this is this is
where is where the spy cam was no it's
worth a shot that's that's not an
insinuation by the way and of course I'm
speaking only of a hypothetical version
of some company that has no relation any
company in reality huh moving rattle
let's move on so we're going to take a
quick lightning round view of some of
the apps that we're going to be looking
at today so we going to go through them
really quickly now and then dig a little
bit deeper later so the first of those
apps grocery IQ
I think can best be described as your
ultimate grocery companion it's got
integration with coupons loyalty cards
it lets you share sync lists between
your friends and your family it has a
lot of really convenient ways to input
items into your list including things
like barcode autocomplete favorites all
of that good stuff so this was one of my
photos i'm looking forward to digging a
little bit deeper into this one out of
mill is less with shopping app and more
of a list management app that happens to
mention shopping is a possible
application now to the physical visual
design is lush it has an animated
background on the opening screen it has
little skeuomorphic touches here and
there and it has a crisp and responsive
UI I that separates lists into three
different categories shopping pantry and
to do and as far as we can tell the idea
behind the app is to stock your pantry
list with the items that you use and
then move them to your shopping list
when you run out and that sounds like a
great idea but as we'll see there are a
few hitches in the execution ah I smooth
with these transitions it's wonderful so
fixing like grocery IQ is a full-service
shopping companion it's got coupons
offers from nearby stores and keeps hold
of all of your loyalty cards and even
offers price comparison which is I think
the only one of these particular apps
which does that it's also entirely in
French which is either a huge bonus or
serious drawback depending on your
perspective so we're going to a little
bit more detail on that later as well
and finally you zoom tasks I think I'm
saying correctly I have no idea no time
you get a time and again we've looked at
apps that had promising functionality
but then found that they cut corners on
polish it's like the developers ran out
of rent money and had to ship but zoom
tests the opposite of that this app does
almost nothing functionality wise but
the Polish is actually above average in
fact it's so good and so simple that
zoom feels less like a nap and more like
a resume from somebody who wants to
create apps for a living
if you look at in that light zoom has
some cool features we're going to take a
particular look at one later on the data
validation animation which i think is
really cool but before we do that let's
talk about today's prescriptions alright
and before we do that I want to a big
shout out to the folks who mentioned
that our audio was in Reverse so we had
the person on the left coming from the
right audio channel whoa no I thought
YouTube wasn't even in stereo for us
apparently this rock on people's heads
hope of this being fixed now thank you
for letting us know this is gonna be
great this is and and it's like total
stereo separation so sort of like the 60
sounds like a Beatles record of
something like which is always yeah I'll
go look I'm over here Ringo's over there
so let's uh let's have a look at the
prescriptions I'm going to put them
behind us because this is going to be up
on screen for a little while indeed so
we're looking at shopping list apps I
think really the acid test here comes
down to one simple question how is this
better for me than a piece of paper and
a pen right because piece of paper fits
in my pocket got them all over the house
load time for a piece of paper is zero
there's no latency there really isn't
your time it's there you don't even have
to do anything neatly you can just
scribble something in your handwriting
do times to whatever and it
automatically makes us spouses never get
mad if you're looking at a piece of
paper and instead of typing your phone
exactly which is in a particularly
important when you're in a shopping
center if you do happen to be holding
your phone up for whatever reason
grocery store seem to be built within
Faraday cages it's a little unexpected
but it means that if you've got an app
which depends on an internet connection
it's really not going to be that useful
for you well I can say this about any
app you know whether you're a grocery
store or not there are going to be dead
zones no matter how great your carrier
is I don't care so you've got to work
without a connection and you've got to
do it seamlessly now also speaking of
wives and spouses I want to be able to
share my list you know I have things
that I need my wife to go pick up when
she's shopping she has things for me
sometimes we go shopping together so I
want to be able to for her to see my
list items I want to see her list items
and when I pick something else up I want
to make sure that it gets checked off on
both our devices so we don't end up with
duplication absolutely and I think
that's a really important point and we
want to make that as simple as possible
so if we are sharing lists and
authenticating ourselves so we can back
things up on the cloud which even
without sharing I want this stuff to
live on the cloud so that it just works
then I can never lose things i want that
authentication flow to be as simple as
possible I don't want to have to go
through four pages and three redirects
just to be able to log in to this to
this app hey I don't even want to type
in my email address all right when we
talked about this before you know every
every click that you have to make to be
able to get to what you want to do is an
opportunity for years ago and to hell
with this and hit the home screen button
and get out of your app if we're going
to count clicks like keystrokes is
clicks as well then it's not going to
get too far into your email address
before they're like that the hell with
this exactly I personally never run a
nap if it asks me to type in my email
address my email address is on the phone
but there's other things that you can do
to save people time to I mean the
shopping apps are the kind of thing
where most people buy the same thing
give me some autocomplete look at my
contacts remember things that go before
I'm sure you know let me add those
things again yeah like I said baka it's
again let me just take a picture I don't
even need to write it down just take a
photo of whatever I want that's enough
to get fine location and microphone
permissions so that if I'm in my bedroom
sobbing and I'm all alone it will remind
me to buy beer it looks like you need
whiskey yeah exactly useful feature I'm
not sure of anything else we looked at
today off of that but I might be going a
little far there but you never know it
it's good to set lofty goals exactly ok
so those are the prescriptions we have
let's see how our apps measured up ok so
yeah let's so let's dig into each of
those and so the first app that we
wanted to take a look at is actually out
of milk which I think you took a look
out so this this is the other
so Google Play listen yeah exactly i
just had one thing to say about this
which is I think that the basic design
of the logo is good it's fun it gets the
point across but that little to-do list
on their feature graphic is probably
twice as big as it needs to be and their
logo is half as big though should really
be rejiggered some but let's not spend
too much time on that let's bring up the
app on our giant fake Ramon oh why isn't
John fake phone coming out well that's
very disappointing what happened I'm not
sure i'll try unplugging it and
replugging it back in that always works
the big reveal for the giant fine okay
it's interesting I'm seeing no lights on
the air on the giant phone controller
I'm gonna duck out of sight I figure out
why that is does this them just get too
hot do you think cuz it seems like this
always fails on a sinner later there's
aa coming up almost now triumph it's
plugging it back in yeah it's coming Oh
giant faith oh well this is a really
good time to remind our audience that we
are doing this live that is why we have
an excuse for this sort of nonsense but
since we're doing it live we'd be happy
to take your feedback producer lewis is
watching the youtube comment stream i
think he's also taking a look at our G+
page so if you want to get in touch with
us and give some questions comments
anything you'd like us to talk about
that we're not already talking about
we'll see if we can squeeze you in we
have been told it in your a little loud
so we probably just excel that's ur
always happens alright so we're going to
try and make eat a little bit quieter
and I'm also going to try and restart
Wyatt cost real quick because good lord
really anyway we're gonna get that video
up maybe so do you stream on pause for a
moment and then you will come back
that's right so we won't be live viewers
we will be realized but do bear with us
don't all run away and we will be back
in just one brief moment it goes we are
still seeing the black I think we're
back now so thank you for your patience
this vehicle is still around
frustratingly we still don't seem to
have any actual video we had it there
for a second deed okay is everyone we uh
it says it's broadcasting okay all right
we're gonna do this baby weatherman
style but nice and all right if you're
still watching the reason we're looking
confused is rato tripped over a cable
Justin Wanda it's okay what can go wrong
just the monitor yeah okay so are we
still going yeah absolutely who just
wasting time excellent always behaving
entirely as expected well thank God we
had an excellent rehearsal but a full
dress rehearsal for this session that's
exactly why everything is better
I really feel the preparation and the
way with its really come together here
absolutely I think the human element is
better it's the technology that lets us
down you know why Computers can't
rehearse that's right all right perfect
okay too quiet now so rate till you want
to drive out of milk so I can be mr
weatherman now one thing that we did in
rehearsal actually that we can't see
that you see what i did there i'm going
to call it rehearsal so one thing we did
earlier that we won't be able to
reproduce is the entry experience in
outer milk is a significant amount of
times it goes through a I think nine or
ten page tutorial which it would have
been nice to be able to skip now the
other thing that out of milk does it is
it asks for me to sign it oh there we go
yeah so it's this thing there's no
obvious way to get pasta some of them
scrolling through the right exactly and
then it asked me to sign in now
additionally the ability to sign in with
Google and with Facebook a couple of
issues there first I would like to sign
in with whoever on it honestly but I
realized that you know standards being
what they are or not that's not
necessarily possible so it's great that
we have google and facebook as options
the only problem is if i try to sign in
with google it takes me to a web page a
web view which i think we don't have
because we're in one of those Faraday
cages exactly you could buy / cece yeah
it's incredible the problem is now there
we go the problem is now I've got to
fill this out and unless I completely
trust this app I shouldn't now this is a
something a lot of people don't know but
I think tech savvy people know this is
that on a phone going through this flow
isn't going to add to your security at
all because the app developer can
actually read directly out of that web
view this Oh auth flow was created for
web apps that run in standards compliant
browsers not in a web view that sits
inside another application so with the
web view or I'm sorry with a web app
on your desktop the question is do you
trust your browser with this sort of
thing the question is do you trust the
random app creator that put this
together personally sorry out milk guys
but I don't so nothing personal he
trusts the snow on so what we'll talk a
little later about how to make that
easier but let's remember that this is
not the way to go if you want your users
to stay engaged tell me so that's not so
what we've got here out on the front
page is against our this dashboard
pattern that you can see this it seems
like an odd fit for this up well it's
kind of cool because you get this you
know a little like moving background
behind there it's it's pretty but it's a
complete waste of space and it's a waste
of my time if I want to categorize my
list that's great but I'm not really
sure that these three categories are the
way that I would do it even if it were I
think I'd prefer to swipe between them
or have some other way of choosing them
rather than that desk or even though the
dashboard is pretty and as you can see
as we're going through each of these
lists they look identical they just have
a different heading and so I really just
want to be able to click this and choose
between those different lists they do
behave a little differently but that's
not actually a plus so for instance
let's check out the shopping list if you
want to add an item you type in the name
of the item or you speak it because it's
got the microphone icon there that's
nice what happens if i add an item from
the pantry list though if I go to the
pantry
I'm automatically given a list of
suggestions to add which is really nice
and I can still type them in which is a
good step but it does show me all these
things would be really nice to have that
same functionality in both parts of yeah
right I mean it you feel like you know
what was going through these guys mind
in thinking oh we've got this great
functionality for the pantry and so
we'll split that off from the shopping
list so it has this different
functionality but it turns out that that
functionality is useful everywhere now
the other thing that I kind of wish this
apt it differently is when it comes to
checking off items I mean what what are
the two things that you always do with
lists apps yeah things in you do you
check them off has done exactly if and
this I think probably just a rule of
thumb that we can say for certain but no
Roman Nurik should probably weigh in on
this but here's what I think if the two
most common behaviors in your entire app
can't be accomplished without I double
tapping or long pressing there's
something wrong with your UI design so
how am I going to check out an item
there so click the item and I can click
done so that that was right so if you if
you just single click you're going to
see that that toolbar come up and that's
great at least it's discoverable but why
isn't there a checkbox just next to the
item exactly in fact if I long press
which isn't particularly discoverable it
does the it does the done but what I
really expect us to do is when I do a
long press to get a contextual action
bar something which let me multi select
items and do many of the things here so
bulk move Alt Delete bolt copy those
sorts of things all part of the context
for actual bar would be a really nice
things about now we talked a lot about
apps where it seems like the developer
ran out of time and to me this is the
this is the evidence I almost have to do
list of stuff that we need to figure out
how it works in E in the UI probably
right there's a gargantuan list of
features that obviously exists in the
bowels of the app but there's no UI to
launch them and there was very little
thought given to how these things fit
together so there's just this jungle
of different things that you might want
to do you know sharing versus settings
versus history all of these things could
be done in a way that makes them task
focused and discoverable but instead
they're sitting on this gargantuan menu
bar that's almost unusable absolutely
and so that's probably the biggest piece
of advice that I would have for the
people behind out of milk is think more
about the typical user workflow one of
the most common things that they were
going to going to want to do make it as
simple as possible you don't want to
have to think about well how do I move
something from like you'll see this
every time I want to change something
I'm clicking like three or four
different places because I don't want to
have to hit back because that implies
that I'm doing something I just want to
change my navigation location so I want
to click here and then choose patulous
but I don't I have to go back and then
click pantries it's already two clicks
and so how do I get my chicken broth
here how do I get that into my shopping
list well and there's no up affordance
on this thing that looks a lot like an
action bar but isn't and again I mean we
say this a lot but you know go nuts with
your custom design but if you make a
design that looks like a built in
android feature either make it work
exactly like it or rethink your design
because otherwise you're just going to
confuse people exactly so really i think
the the suggestions i would have here is
simplifying navigation simplify your
workflow optimize the app for whatever
the most typical or desirable workflow
is so it should be really easy to add
things to your shopping lists using all
the autocomplete magic which is in
pantry when you've bought things it
should move into your pantry because
you've bought them so another in your
pantry and then from there you should be
able to click do a single click which
then moves it back into your shopping
list and so then you'll have an app
which continues to grow and become more
and more useful the more you use it
without having to do a lot of pre
population are no one is going to sit
down and put everything that they
currently have in that pantry into this
into this app to make their life
potentially easier in the future it
needs to build myself exactly well i
think we probably spent enough time
talking about the particular things that
out of milk may have
have done right or wrong why don't we
talk a little bit about some of the
technical things that they might be able
to do to make this app a little better
friendlier absolutely amazing to it
what's my clicker which is handy mm-hmm
it's uh oh it's over here yeah yes so so
one of the things which this app does
which a lot of these apps do or at least
one of the key pieces of functionality
is sharing lists and so the way that you
do that is you choose someone you want
to share it with sends them an email
says hey you know this this has been
shed you can follow a link to it now
what would be really neat is if you
could take that one step further and
actually have that link automatically
open up your ad exactly and it doesn't
even have to be emails any web link
that's right that that I want to have do
something in my ass right you know
browsing the web site associated with
this or someone you know if you wife
tweets you link because that's just how
she rolls sure you want that all to work
you got your bitly link or whatever yeah
precise sure so what you want to do is
you can actually intercept any URL to
click within an application by
registering an intent filter against the
activity that wants to react to it and
so what happens then is whenever that
URL is clicked within a webview browser
text you anything really it's going to
launch a new view intent and the URL
associated with with that click action
is going to be included as a data
parameter so if you can create an intent
filter like this one and that's you can
see here that's specifying the the host
the protocol type that scheme i should
say and the path so it's really
important so here we're going to say
we're going to intercept links for my
website but not everything I still want
people to be able to view my website on
the device but if they click on a shared
shopping list then that's something that
my app can handle and so you can do
something really clever with this in
that
you can have your actual website
redirect to google play or to a please
download my app type link so if if the
app is installed you can view the shared
of straight away if it isn't then you
can encourage people to the store yeah
so if the apps installed it'll just eat
that link because it fit that particular
form of my website or exam of the apps
website but if the apps not installed
then it's going to cruise right past and
into the web browser or whatever you
have set up to handle generic links and
in fact the user is going to be prompted
with the opportunity to either use your
app to to launch to fulfill that link or
to view in the browser so the option is
still there is something that YouTube
does is something that the google maps
does all to try and create that magical
experience now I have to I have to admit
the first thing that came into my head
when I heard you talking about this is
well what if I just intercept my google
play link oh that's interesting so why
would you want to do that well maybe I
don't want to set up but maybe I don't
want to set up a server I don't want to
set up a redirect maybe I don't have the
ability to do that see that would be the
challenge because you're wanting to
intercept a link using an app it isn't
installed indeed but that's the whole
point though right if the if the app is
not installed we go to Google Play if it
is installed so if someone tries to
follow a link to your app yes in your
app is installed you want to open your
app incentive I'm not saying me but a
friend of mine asked a guy you know yeah
I guess you can do that i'm not entirely
sure what the use case would be for it
but I we actually have had that that
question go through tech support hey guy
so yeah I guess that's interesting so
probably better to put a redirect in
because you want to have some some
control over what you're doing and I and
you definitely don't want to be in the
position where users can't get to your
play late to update or to see reviews or
whatever or you know God for me to mess
it up and end up hijacking play for
everybody so
I bring it up as a counterexample but
some really interesting things you can
do with this so let's have a look one of
the I think there was another technical
activity well actually you know I was
thinking about how much I hate typing in
my email address and there hasn't really
been a wonderful way here for to fix
that but we just recently released
something called google play services
and it turns out that the google play
services API which is a an extra in the
android sdk just like billing or
licensing or these other things that you
add on has a way to register and you
know essentially federated counts
without having to write a bunch of code
without having to deal with a loss and
importantly without having to request
extra permissions nice so what what you
want to do is same thing i did which is
check out this link it's the google
developers link that's where the google
play services live because a google api
it's not an Android API but it's really
nice add-on and you're more or less
guaranteed to have it on the system if
you have froyo or above and a recent
version of market now it's not exactly
that easy but it's really close this is
a backwards compatible library you don't
have to update the phone there's no OTA
involved as long as you read the
documentation you'll understand how to
use it so what can you do with this well
let's take a look at this code first
thing that you often want to do is get
the user's account so that you can
figure out who this user is so Google
Play services has a nice convenience
method to help you do that this works
back to froyo now we did add a
convenience similar convenience method
to the framework in ICS this backwards
compatible so you just launched this
intent and it will launch the
picker dialog for accounts and you can
say which type of accounts you want in
this case com google is the name of a
account and that will bring you back a
string that in fact I think it's on the
next slide we'll we'll use that string
and on activity result the string will
be an identifier for the account now
you'll probably notice immediately that
the identifier for Google accounts is
actually your gmail address but you
can't count on that that's not at all
required and it very well may change in
the future so what you really want is an
ID that you can associate with this user
to tell you two things first they are
who they say they are in in the sense
that it's really them saying sure use my
account and second you have some sort of
ID that you can use to federate you know
you haven't you have an idea that where
you can store in your database so it's
not going to change and every time you
see that ID come from an android device
you know oh yeah that's this key in my
database so the way you do that in this
example is use the user profile API now
this is actually I think it's a an open
ID leftover actually but you don't need
to know anything about open ID to use it
all you do is specify the OAuth scope
which I actually have to do a little
digging for so I made sure and put it in
this slide I it's you know auth colon
blah blah blah blah and ended up with
user profile now once you've got the
scope you send it to Google core I'm
sorry google play services and it will
try to acquire you a token there's two
things that can happen at this point you
either get a token or you get a response
back that says sorry you can't have a
token but here's why and here's the way
to fix it because usually the reason you
don't have a token because the user
hasn't actually authorized you to look
at their information so if you launch
that intent what you'll get is a very
nice little dialogue that essentially
says this app wants to look at your
basic profile
data do you want to allow them and as
long as the user clicks there and says
yes then you'll get a token back that
you can use to make web service calls to
this API now if you like me the first
time you get into calling web services
it feels a little tricky yeah
fortunately with this API it couldn't be
easier let's take a look at the next
piece of code all you do is get a URL
connection and set up the particular URL
with the token that you were given so
that's all you need to do it's a one
call thing and the response you get back
we'll actually contain the users profile
data it's a JSON format and we can take
a look at that right now oh so this is
an example of what you get back if you
query my profile data for instance you
get my my name or at least what I told
google my name is and you've got a date
of birth but no year huh no email
address no way to contact made people
have their ad a year of birth sort of
tied to their email address it could be
tricky if you go I have you gave that
access ah that's quite possible or it
could just be the year of a very
pleasant scotch that you drank once
that's quite possible indeed the
important thing here is is you're
getting enough information to be able to
identify this person when they come back
so there's some you get the first name
last name so you can actually refer to
them by name people love that but more
importantly you get an ID this is
actually their Google+ ID which is tied
to that user and won't change the way an
email address might or the the way a
name might in fact absolutely absolutely
that's really nice so don't don't make
your users type in email addresses and
passwords anymore this is a
click-through interface that does the
exact same thing and unlike the web view
that we saw earlier it's secure
which is a nice touch indeed all right
so to move on let's move on let's have a
look at the the next app that we wanted
to check out is a grocery IQ look my
head is an IQ that's gonna be first time
for everything this is enough let's take
a look it's so this this is an app that
I quite like grocery IQ is probably my
favorite of the apps that we look at
today and you can tell that the
developers behind this app have really
spent a lot of time and effort trying to
create something that is fully featured
as possible you've got all this the
obvious sorts of stuff that you like so
you can see here it's got autocomplete
which is nice and fast and rich and it
actually goes a step further you can see
here once you've ordered once you've
added these things in it automatically
character categorizes them for you as
well which is a really nice tip you can
see all of the sort of obvious things
are right there you've got the the
checkbox next to things as well so you
can just add things she lists really
easily check them off really easily and
so it's got that call functionality of
what is this out for how does this make
my life easier is really obvious right
off the bat which is nice exactly so one
thing that I really love about this app
is the way that it knows everything
already yeah and unfortunately we can't
show this but it actually does have
pictures that would actually be sitting
right along here nice i'll show you a
little bottle of whiskey for instance
because it's just in case well yeah in
case you forgot well and this can be
really useful because it seems kind of
obvious it's like well I've added to the
list so I know what it looks like except
that maybe someone else Adams the list
and you don't know what it looks like
and so having a picture right there from
something someone else added is really
useful and this is a really good example
of an app which is trying to one-up
paper so we're paper is just whatever
you wrote down here you get to know what
categories in which means you know what
islets in and you can then sort by I'll
so you can make sure that your shopping
trip is actually optimized using the
Traveling Salesman problem yeah it's
amazing how the the presence of these
cloud databases just can change the most
mundane app into something really
magical
I don't think there's a worldwide
database and I certainly couldn't find a
lot of my favorite things in this
particular app but I can see that if I'm
in the right location it's really really
handy because not only does it know the
sorts of things that might be available
it also knows what they cost and can
compute the tax for me so it can do a
lot of mundane tasks without me even
thinking about it I love that absolutely
and I think that's what this app does
really really well is it has thought
about this workflow and so the first
time I use it it's instantly useful
that's already adding things to my list
which I wouldn't have thought of so all
the data that pulls down from the web
around the products that i'm adding is
instantly useful pictures cost
categories all of those things are great
and what I really like is that they've
gone that extra step so by default is
just going to go to your grocery store
but you can actually add your own shops
so there's a whole food to safeway near
my place that I shop at you can then add
the aisles that they have and we order
them that's right I I found that by
pressing on grocery store had a little
chat on there but what was disappointing
is once I started looking at a list that
has just two options any store or
grocery store and thinking wow it would
be nice to add another store to this
then I didn't know how yeah it seems
like they missed a golden opportunity
here to make the appt flow even more
magical by looking at this and saying
well if a user sees an incomplete list
what are they going to want to do add
something to it so why put that anywhere
else why put that functionality
somewhere else be nice to see these
working in the same way that the account
manager work so you can choose between
your account so you can add one that's
not there in it it helps you to
understand the functionality that this
app provides and there's a lot of it and
so I'm trying to put that from the
center and easy to sort of expand your
use of the app is I think a really over
it does a lot of clever things like when
you have checked out so once you've
family remember list out of TV history
making it easier for you to then add
things back for future list adding
favorite is really simple but this is
something that that you actually pointed
out to it to me in is the favorite time
it could be a little bit sensible mm-hmm
that's a word I love that word let's use
it it's a bar yeah well like you pointed
out the favorites tab here already has a
star on it why don't I just see that
star in the list here exactly and in
fact if you look at that list they may
be a golden opportunity here because we
have these carrots over on the side here
which kind of meaningless in an Android
world at least yeah today I think it
makes sense if you're on an OS where
there you're guaranteed to get a
right-to-left sliding animation when you
move from a list item to a detail but
that's not what Android does it has a
zoom animation yeah and like a funky
kind of vortex zoom icon raid but we
would do that because we're not insane
yeah particularly because and this is
the important thing is that the
animation between activities isn't
guaranteed and it can be changed by OEMs
by different platform versions and so
you don't want to make any assumptions
as to what screen animation is going to
happen when you click something on the
screen you really don't so what we've
just trained users to think in Android
is that if you click on a list item it
will take you to the details for that
list item precisely that is just an
expected behavior so there's no point in
putting a chevron here but you could
certainly fill that space with something
else a star there's a checkbox on the
other side if you wanted to you could
even go nuts this is a little bit small
but no you can usually get away with one
or two things on the right-hand side
that have nothing to do with the details
for that list item because it makes your
users life easier and of course there's
always the idea of putting a little tear
off corner to bring up a contextual item
let's sort it too long press for
contextual items absolutely so I think
that would be a nice thing you'll be you
know really simple
place the character with stars and then
just add that favorites flow directly
into either experience you have a couple
of things I wanted to highlight reel
quik is is up the top here we have
coupons so we've got coupons we've got
loyalty card integration it's basically
everything that you could want and it's
really an app that's really spent a lot
of time thinking about what is it that
you want a replacement shopping list
piece of paper to do to really enrich
the experience and make it something
that you can justify using instead of
just writing yeah and like you said it
really builds on itself it's useful the
moment it loads and as I want more
functionality it's relatively easy to
find so even though the design of this
app is fairly dated and you can tell
that the buttons that come from the
froyo era and the tab bar hasn't really
been used in a while and probably do a
viewpager and some other nice things
doesn't matter the the core design the
flow of the application has been really
well thought out to make it easy for
users to get the most out of it although
I did need to point out and this is just
for that one dude that was on our
YouTube page earlier this is a menu
button of shame shame shame that's a but
really what it is is just a really
obvious example of the fact that this is
an average people spend a lot of time
and effort making really great probably
hasn't been updated from that design
perspective since the initial designs
when this app came out and it's
absolutely the big piece of feedback
we've we would have for grocery IQ love
the app let's say maybe take the
opportunity now that the whole thing's
been out for a while we have the design
site so you no longer have to play the
guessing game of what the android guys
going to do next right it's up there
it's being pretty standard and that's
definitely a style and a design that
we're going to be sticking with for a
while so now I think it's a great
opportunity to maybe think about a
tablet app think about doing a redesign
in fact Roman Nick and Adam are going to
be performing a design makeover on
grocery IQ next Tuesday so it will be
interesting to see what
and stay tuned by the way we don't have
a time yet for this but sometime in the
next couple weeks we are going to do an
interview with the design team and they
are going to explain the whole menu
button issue and we are going to get set
straight so yeah that should be
interesting stay tuned for that right so
there's a couple of specific technical
implementation details which I wanted to
cover as well so these are things that
grocery IQ does well well could do
better and again i think in both of the
cases here at stuff which is probably
post dates when this app was built so
hopefully the stuff that we can point
out to the developers and they can
implement as well absolutely that little
bit neater so the first is around the
way that the app sends updates okay
right now there is a menu option that
you can select to say how often you want
it to pull the service to check pull the
servers ya seen the problem right there
right yeah yeah hey nineteen eighty-five
called they want their data update
method back so and the bad news is the
highest number you can see is five
minutes which kind of makes sense
because I want my shopping list to be
bang up to date but I really don't know
that I want my phone firing up the cell
network and transferring data back and
forth between the server there's got to
be a better way it has to be an in fact
it is a better way and that's Google
Cloud messaging and that's what I'm
going to attempt to display on the
screen behind me I see start off with
your app that's running on each of the
users phones so that's what we're
looking at up here now what you need to
do first is register the phone with the
Google Cloud messaging server and that's
going to uniquely identify this device
with a particular user on it with Google
that's then going to send a message back
up to the device i'm going to start
pointing because clearly i'm bad at this
weather presenter not in my future ah
but so what you now have on each of the
devices is a
unique address which you can then use
from your server via google cloud
messaging to talk to that particular app
so the next thing you need to do is
actually send that down to your server
and now what your server has hopefully
is a hash of the username or user
identifier that has logged into that
particular phone and that phone combined
and now you have an address that you can
send messages using so you're basically
all set to go so what happens now is a
user using their tablet at home makes a
change to a shopping list you send that
down to your server your server goes oh
okay yep updated the lists now I need
everyone to who has access to the shared
list to see what the changes are so it
is now going to send a message to the
google cloud messaging to each of those
apps using the addresses which you've
got registered with it Google Cloud
messaging is then going to send that to
each of the devices which are going to
get pinged using 10th receiver they're
going to go oh okay look I have changes
to this so they then have the option to
ping the server and ask for those
specific updates or if it's small enough
change you can actually package it in
the payload of the message that you're
going to send look Ian's in the cloud so
that's basically how it works and so you
don't ever have to do pauling you're
basically just updating the server and
the server is directly transmitting that
information to each of the devices which
need to be updated yay okay so that's a
that's a great tip and something that
you should really check into is that
really cost you anything yeah all rights
it's entirely cost-free that it does
save your device your users devices a
lot of battery life and actually means
that their latency between changes is
reduced as well so it's how do we went
exactly no of course this isn't magic I
mean it's not like we're you know we
don't have a way to just phone up that
device there still is polling involved
but the important thing is that all of
the messages are set in one batch
instead of each app making its own
network connection and possibly screwing
up the network connection using not only
the bandwidth but battery and CPU time
as well exactly okay so there was
another tip as well which I wanted to
point out and that is about how to share
those contact with so at the moment you
hit share this list and it will pop up a
dialog asking for an email address which
is reasonable but I don't memorize email
address no I don't remember as anything
phone numbers email I don't because it's
all in my gmail or my google plus and
all that seek to my phone so every way I
have to contact with someone is already
in the phone so I kind of resent having
to type something that already exists
yeah so rather than asking users to copy
and paste email addresses you can use
the contact picker so they can choose a
contact from the existing contact list
and the way that works is actually
pretty straightforward you start by
creating an intent again a lot of things
tend to work with intense and this time
the action is pick and the cop then the
data that you want to pick from his
contacts or to put it more specifically
if slightly less clearly the contacts
contracts content provider well I love
them yeah these things are actually just
made to be tongue twisters as Italy we
love the alliteration here at Android so
it will be a lot of aid words as much as
we can anyway so you say that that
intense start an activity full results
oh that's going to then open up contacts
picker users going to click on something
and it's going to send you back a you
are I and what this massive screen full
of code does is actually pretty
straightforward we get a URI to a
particular contact back from the contact
picker we're going to extract that ID by
using a query on on the content provider
once we have that we're going to use
that idea then make another query this
time on the database or the content
provider which contains the email
addresses so we're basically going to
say we have this ID what is the
associated email and that's what you see
here is that that last part of actually
pulling out the email address from the
the query result of that cursor so once
you've done that you've got the email
address it's good form to then just pop
that into the the editor
to make sure the user can confirm it
modified if necessary before you got and
send off the email cool so it's it's a
fairly straightforward process and I
think something which really makes life
a lot easier and in fact you can
possibly even go a step further here
which is well you have the email address
and if you're logging people in using
their email addresses then maybe I need
to send them an email if they already
have an account maybe you can just send
a notification director define exactly
maybe can your boat maybe you could do
five exactly so let's have a look so
let's let's move on to the to the next
app which was zoom tools exactly so zoom
tasks has a gorgeous feature graphic and
really nice design and honestly it does
almost nothing it's I mean it's it's a
bare-bones to house evidence being
beautiful it which has all of the
marketing stuff done perfectly it's
really an example exactly what you
should do to make sure that your app is
likely to be downloaded actually yeah
absolutely there's a ton of stuff that
we could talk about starting with where
they got that check mark I don't think
we should even show that probably i'm
going to end up in a sweat shop in
southeast asia somewhere um but what i
did want to point out is what happens
when you fill out a form incorrectly hmm
obviously you never want to punish your
user for doing something but there are
certain cases where you have to do data
validation you know that there's
probably something wrong when you've
tried to add a task without name for
instance well that's that's the example
they chose sorry I hit okay here but I
haven't put in a task holler if you see
that it's wiggling exactly wow I love it
it's gonna no no no so it's a universal
signal that you got something wrong in
this particular piece of you I pay
attention to this bit right but it
doesn't give you a toast that says
please do not press that button again it
doesn't give you a dialogue that says
you screwed up press ok to accept this
and move on with your life
instead it just gives you a little nudge
to say something a little off here this
right this isn't the only way you could
do it I mean you could turn the field
red you could put a like so Mason point
next to it the point is that you want
your data validation to be a
uninterested your text in order to
figure out what they did wrong this is
beautiful because I could use this even
if I didn't speak English yeah I love
this feature and I really like the way
that they've implemented this particular
little shake it's it's buttery it's nice
and it just gets the job done and that's
I think kind of the the resounding theme
to this app is that it's designed really
well it's it's simple it's got those
nice little bits of polish but almost
ironically or certainly different for my
usual expectations the polish is there
the functionality is now in fairness we
are comparing it in a category up
against apps that are designed to
optimize the shopping experience rather
than specifically to do lists which is
really more an example of but even still
if you look at an apps like tasks from
our tasks team they kind of do a need a
job apart from anything else this
doesn't synchronize to a service
anywhere so if it's the only place that
I can get to it is on my device if my
device gets flash this is gone forever
yep and that's that's kind of a kind of
sucks yeah yeah that gets old okay so I
don't think we want to talk about zoom
tasks anymore and we are just about out
of time if we were going by real-world
time as opposed to the fake time that we
use when we screw stuff up in the middle
of the show and then that time doesn't
count no it does not so let's have a
look so one of the I think the last act
we wanted to look at was prick single
pre depending on how you choose to
mispronounce the French way and I think
about this app the defining feature of
this up is that it is entirely in French
right which is fine there's this
certainly no problem with that except
that we we don't speak French know so
it's a difficult for us but for us to
fairly sort of evaluate it and so
we're really going too much detail I
will say that I wanted to use it because
if you looking really really pretty
they've used pictures everywhere that
makes senses there isn't any boring text
it's laid out like a magazine and really
really like it it makes you want to go
shopping exactly the only concern that I
have is as I tap on some of these
beautiful pictures it's taking me to web
views it's taking me out of the app so i
do question any app that launches a
webview makes me think well maybe this
app isn't actually all that functional
yeah it takes me out to the end up
having to go to the browser at or work
for you to do that functionality again
it's I want to be totally fair without
knowing exactly what we're pressing it
may say click here to view this on a web
page but this that's quite true that
might be right this this particular
style picture might be the universal I'm
a web page picture in certain
french-speaking areas of world we have
no idea yeah it looks like a really
fully featured absolutely the reviews
that it gets on google play a very very
encouraging is a beautiful looking app
it's got things like coupons and you
know loyalty cards and all the sorts of
stuff that we saw in grocery IQ and out
of milk but unfortunately we can't
really review it because we don't speak
the language now that doesn't actually
bring up to you kind of important point
and one is that should kind of be able
to use an app like this without being
able to speak the language which it's
written in possibly yeah it may be a
stretch but here I wasn't able to get
very far at all before just going I
don't know what to do I can't believe
you don't even have like French speaking
friends though I probably well I mean as
a shame is no friend you're not even
American and retain would be no yeah
anyway but said so that might be a tip
so and this this goes for people writing
english language apps as well see what
happens when you translate all of your
apps into gibberish and see whether it's
usable
that's a fantastic idea yeah that's a
really good way to see how does the
three work what are the UX fuzz testing
that's likely yeah it's like well if you
put this in front of someone and they
don't know what the words arc and they
still figure it out does what are the
buttons they're pressing by default
because whatever flow their do
instinctively you want to be the right
flow and so you want the words to just
back up what they intuitively feel like
they should be doing and the other tip
of course is maybe consider an English
translation there's a lot of English
speakers it's probably one of the one or
if not the largest market in terms of
your Android consumers are going to be
English speakers so consider investing
in that translation particular because
purchasing has been around for a while
really popular a great way to grow your
user base unless the apps only useful in
France or french-speaking places in
which case it makes a lot of sense to go
ahead and just take it out of the
english-speaking market because remember
anytime that you have your app presented
to people who aren't going to be able to
use it whether it's because their phone
isn't high-tech enough or they don't
have the right api level or in this case
they don't have they don't speak the
language that you do you're going to get
at least some people who are frustrated
and give you bad reviews because of that
and you don't deserve that you want to
make sure that you are you know we
encourage people to build out such a
usable by as many different people in
many different devices as possible if
you choose not so that's fine that you
know don't don't encourage negative
feedback by offering it to people who
aren't going to be able to use exactly
cool well I think that gets us to the
end of our app lyft absolutely that's uh
let's take a look at some of the
specific prescriptions that we have for
these app that so these are the right
that we would love people to do to take
the apps to the next life absolutely i
can't wait before we do though it occurs
to me that we haven't checked in with
producer lewis in a while hey producer
lewis how's the YouTube stream going you
going very well there a question from
grocery iq being available in Central
Europe it appears that it is not okay so
their concerns about Geographic
availability mm-hmm people are very
excited to see the code samples are
encouraged to use the cloud in terms of
publishing their apps now spent it very
good good to hear there also some inputs
feedback for talking about how you would
get prices for items from different
stores and put them into the app exit
probably unusual that people will do
that and shop around but for those who
want to they would like to be able to
add that to apps like grocery IQ I think
that's a great idea although that sounds
like no I'm sorry did we Mike producer
louis yet you allowed me to work for you
i hope so so yes he's not coming turn
okay well it just in case the so the the
question the last question is around
collecting information from different
stores pricing information things like
that absolutely but i think this seems
like one of those things where there's a
business opportunity absolutely right i
mean i could go around to a bunch of
stores and collect price information but
what would be even more interesting is
if i sent a dozen guys around with you
know backpack cameras or something and
they collect its price information for
me and then i put that in the cloud and
monetized in some way so something to
think about it i think it's an
interesting challenge when you're
looking at price comparison especially
for it to be really useful within an app
you want to be able to pull in a
real-time feed of prices for all the
different competitive supermarkets
particularly talking about groceries and
i'm sure those api's exist but probably
not in a way that will allow you to do
exactly that because a sabre system for
groceries it's probably not what the
grocery stores want you to do no have
the same list and know exactly which
shop to go to I'll tell you let me give
you a real world example though because
as we've discussed on the store that the
whole point of going to college and and
working for google is that I don't have
to count pennies on my grocery bill so i
don't i don't care how much my beer
costs unless it's up at one place that
sells the 995 beer for 1795 those guys
ripped me off man
but I'll tell you what what I do count
calories so yeah after after working for
google for three years and 30 pounds
heavier than i was when i started love
to get my calories down that's something
that i would love to see budgeted in a
shopping app and it just so happens that
at least in the United States the FDA
the government has a database of many
different foods and their nutritional
information and you can see apps that do
this there's I think the wid things app
dozen there's several fitness apps that
do it but it would be great if that
could be in the shopping app to again
because this is really going back to
what we were saying it's really about
trying to add as much functionality as
you can which you would have to go to
other places and the beauty of this is
you have to create a shopping list and
what really talking about here is
incentivizing you to do that shopping
list in this app by saying if you write
it down here once then suddenly will be
able to give you recipe ideas based on
the things that you've bought we'll be
able to tell you the caloric intake of
the things that you which were in this
list we can keep track of your
international breed buying budget over
time to see whether it's trending upward
trending down these are the sorts of
things which I think can really add
benefit exactly telex let's go ahead and
take a look will step out of the way of
out of milk and again I think we
mentioned this before would be would
have been useful to to copy this text
somewhere we could actually read it but
we'll let you guys read it and give I
guess over all right well I can almost
read it because I have better eyes than
a is dead now so yeah it glosses but the
good folks in the a Google Drive team
keep them off my face and soccer this
week so uh I've had to remember oh you
don't even know what that cost me to set
that up okay um so 4 out of milk there
are several design things that we would
like to be seen but I the functionality
seems really nice and we just like it to
be easier to get to so how about the
contacts picker how about letting me
sign in with my account without having
to put in my email address let's go on
then so the next step was a grocery IQ
and we really really like this app why
did we put this me home
can we talk about it in front oh there
we go okay great all right you know what
I can't actually read it I wanted the
thing about grocery IQ I think really
what it comes down to apart from the
specific things that we've got there oh
look at us you read oh oh I see so we
can actually rate oh that's cool wow
thanks for this Chromebook Lewis I can't
believe how useful it is ok I think the
key thing for me for grocery IQ is you
know you've got great designers they
created a really great work flow user
flow for an earlier time in the Android
ecosystem and I love love love to see
this app with the same functionality
just and the same designers frankly but
just making it consistent with what we
currently expect to see in android yeah
it just needs to be updated and needs to
use google cloud messaging instead of
pulling that's really important and then
as we said with with the other apps a
little bit tighter integration in terms
of contacts URLs and account management
would be really welcomed basically all
the things we're talking about have been
relatively recently added to Android and
so I think it it literally is a case for
this app of something which has been
designed has done really really well as
the functionality it needs and now it's
just need to have those occasional
refreshes to take advantage than you
features bro Andrew profile has move
along so zoom tasks keep going keep on
truckin buddy so it's beautiful it's
wonderful to see someone who's putting
so much thought and effort into the
design side definitely an inspiration
for people in terms of what you should
be doing on your Google Play listing in
terms of your icon design to create
something really compelling just need to
follow through down and see some more
functionality add it into me you know
what's going to happen now what's gonna
happen Romans going to pick this one for
Android design in action and he's going
to prove us wrong he's going to just
tell us how everything should be
different happily I've looked into the
future and i happen to know we should
the two apps that Roman will be
reviewing so I it won't be certain tasks
myself
because now that i think about it zoom
tests didn't have any gradients anywhere
so Roman wouldn't care what's Roman
probably loves it I probably does and
the last thought we looked at was was
prick Singh and prick Singh the the main
problem for us is that we just don't
speak this language I don't know why we
reviewed it not speaking the language we
love a challenge and we just wanted to
just sort of flaunt our ignorance if I'm
like we need to flaunt it it's clearly
obvious to anyone who cares to look it
actually was the highest scored app both
on the trailer page and on moderator
people really wanted us to look at it
yeah which implies there are a lot of
French speakers watching the show so
punctual and that's about as far as I
can go in front and that's only because
it's also network protocol so we will
lie maybe get some french speakers out
here too absolutely the opposite well
maybe get the entire graphics team is
French basically exactly too much of a
stretch perfect so that was each of the
apps that we wanted to look at and we're
basically up to an hour so that's that's
all for today's app clinic Roman Nick
and Adam will be performing a design
makeover of some of today's apps in
particularly going to look at grocery IQ
and out of milk which is great they're
two of our favorites and that will be on
Android design in action on Tuesday and
will also be checking in on the patients
which we looked at today and in the
previous week's over the next few weeks
to see how they're coming along great
now make sure you visit our Trello page
to nominate the apps and the categories
you'd like to see us review we've
decided to move away from moderator
because Trello is way more hip who
through moderator on the ground not a
part of their system next week we'll be
looking at Trello to see if anyone has
nominated halloween themed apps rato was
convinced that such a thing existed
pumpkins on everyone's playa believed
that there was no such thing I may have
been proven wrong though since so next
week it's going to be trick or treat
we're going to we're going to review
whatever we feel like exactly if if you
are satisfied with Ian proving me wrong
then by all means
nominate any further apps if you would
like to see me proven right please
please oh absolutely if you have a candy
scanner if you have a where's the best
house in the neighborhood for loot if
you have a way something that
automatically locates homemade popcorn
balls and UNICEF pennies go ahead
nominate that stuff we want to see it
I'm sure it exists I refuse to believe
that they done I think people are just
bugging the good Halloween apps because
I don't want other people if everyone
has an app that tells you where the best
place to get candies then there are no
best places to get candy oh the
incredibles quote nice well we'll see
next week we're going to try it out see
what happens in our special Halloween
episode where I think I'll be going as a
doctor standing I don't know how you
come up with these things no I'm clever
that way thanks for joining us my name
is really mine I me Andy Lewis and this
was the athletic take care of watching